les gars est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un ici
besoin d'aide nous apportons de l'eau et de la nourriture
rove rhodes plus d'exemplaires
ici le partenaire m'a trouvé un est
un os de la jambe et il est très court
une personne de moins de 16 ans
promenons-nous ici pour voir si
ceci si vous trouvez autre chose
aux collègues ceci s'il vous plaît si nous
ils veulent soutenir ici
à propos du vieux mexique ford en californie
ce mois-ci entre les grands thèmes et
l'état des centenaires si stupides est un ami
du groupe des banques de médias
prend fin
[Musique]
je m'appelle angel martinez je viens d'oaxaca
Je suis le président de cette organisation
casiers recherche et sauvetage saint
Diégo
dans le désert la chaleur est si extrême
que les chaussures avec la chaleur s'enlèvent
ce sont les bateaux à eau qu'ils
charger dans le désert
comme un solaire pour recharger leur
Téléphone (s
dans le désert des jumelles une chaussure
un enfant on ne sait pas ce qui est arrivé à ça
enfant s'il a réussi à traverser le désert non
réussi à traverser le désert
va faire la queue pour trouver ça, je suis sûr
Je vais manger ça parce que c'est la vie
dans le désert le désert il n'y a rien
quoi manger il n'y a pas d'eau non rien
ensuite
si j'étais l'un d'eux et que je passais
fandería
quand je traverse le désert
J'avais 17 ans les deux premières fois
que nous avons essayé l'arbre 4 que nous lui avons donné
grâce à l'émigration
nous avons découvert que nous n'étions pas morts
la troisième fois que si nous réussissions à passer
Nous avons aussi beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup souffert
parce que nous nous sommes perdus en chemin
nous souffrons beaucoup je sais comment tu souffres
désert
C'est pourquoi je suis là pour m'aider
personnes
[Musique]
bonjour je sors ferme et droit à
Wow
nous donnons un coup de pied à tous les camarades
dormir retour
dans ce lieu et j'aime voir souligné ainsi
Eh bien, nous étions il peut y avoir beaucoup de bénédictions
Ils les aiment
et nous sommes tous des volontaires nous avons tous
une famille nous avons des enfants
nous avons tous un travail parce qu'il travaille à
construction d'autres travaillent dans le
jardiner dans les restaurants, etc., mais
nous avons une mission je pense à ça
durée de vie
peut-être que dans la rue nous serons amis
mais quand nous entrons dans le désert nous sommes
famille
pour moi les immigrés c'est mon frère
Apparemment une pierre est tombée sur lui
quand ça arrive
dimanche dernier qu'ils m'ont laissé
mon oncle alors je ne sais pas comment je peux faire
pour m'aider alors vous avez
coordonnées et tout était plus ou moins nous
ils ont envoyé plus d'homme il nous envoie il me le donne
par WhatsApp tous tous tous les
informations que vous avez s'il vous plaît où
il est resté combien de temps il a marché où
s'est passé pour que cela puisse être plus
facile de les localiser
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour les postes que je
J'envoie toutes ces informations andrés alors
ils doivent être laissés, je suis vraiment désolé
[Musique]
nous marchons là où rien d'autre
les migrants et nous marchons
les voitures entrent elles n'entrent pas les motos n'entrent pas
les chevaux
il y a une crise à la frontière et tous les
jour chaque jour passe
les gens et chaque jour ils meurent
personnes
robert me copie
non mais il y a des os alors allons-y
saisir les coordonnées de vos os vers le haut
de les signaler au centre et mg cinema
ils apportent
dans votre bateau ces types de programmes sont de
mineur et fichier ce que les conservateurs
[Musique]
tige
et je ne suis plus mes parents
mort en mon père est mort en décembre
Je suis allé lui rendre visite et quand j'ai dit au revoir à
lui et il m'a dit mon jeu prends soin de toi maintenant
n'y allez pas le désert est très dangereux
car lui qui était émigré et lui aussi
traversé le désert
à présent
n'est plus en eux
et je sens que
maintenant avec plus de force j'avance
faire ce travail
le plus fort c'est le travail c'est de donner
des nouvelles aux proches qui ont perdu
à un être cher ils nous envoient et nous disent
tu sais qu'il y a mon fils, ma fille sait
il est resté dans un tel endroit ils l'ont laissé et nous sommes arrivés
à l'endroit en espérant toujours pouvoir
les retrouver vivants
mais cela à la fin beaucoup d'entre eux ne le font pas
on se retrouve vivant
nous le faisons depuis de nombreuses années et
pas encore
nous n'avons pas enlevé le désir parce que
être le besoin est ici ici dans
ces places
de Disney
scorpions
l'équipe intime en morale et sport de
soyez mesdames les montagnes
le désert est un cimetière
très grand cimetière
nous voudrions qu'elle ne soit plus
des morts
c'est un si grand endroit si vaste que
je pense que
il y a beaucoup de vies là-bas dans ce désert
mais quand la mémoire
non
eh bien, il n'a pas de nourriture pas beaucoup de jours comme ça
Une fois qu'ils se sont fatigués et ont laissé ça
abandonnés qui les ont peut-être attrapés
migration
on ne sait pas mais ici c'est très difficile de
que la migration n'entre ici qu'avec
l'hélicoptère peut augmenter car ni
avec des motos et marcher tout ce que vous savez
comment est la route
[Musique]
allongez-vous concurrencez que vous mouillez votre
aisselles
jambes entre les jambes
Si tu ne vas pas pouvoir, je le jure, ça n'arrivera pas
arriver
Honnêtement, vous n'allez pas mourir, nous le sommes
en parlant de coeur de 23 jours que cela
ne va pas pouvoir n'est pas beaucoup dans beaucoup
les routes que nous venons d'emprunter le matin
ils ont voyagé assez haut
mais tout va bien pour toi alors allons-y
faire est ok ok et a déjà récupéré est déjà
quelque chose d'autre que vous pouvez aller sur terre maintenant
frère est allé à tijuana ou quelque chose comme ça et toi
tu récupères et encore c'est ok
ok voies aériennes devant m
[Musique]
dans le salon de la prison d'evín et
vérité
wickmayer à ferrol monter en diviser leur
intérieurs mobiles
J'étais sur le point de mourir quand ils sont arrivés
les ambulanciers avaient déjà marché cinq
jours sans eau et sans nourriture puis
J'étais pratiquement déjà en train de mourir
soif et faim
croissance
Aujourd'hui j'étais dans un hôpital d'ici à là
et c'est en route
à la vie
la montre
mais non
[Musique]
et j'aime mes amis comme ma famille
quand nous entrons dans le désert je m'occupe d'eux
nous n'allons pas nous quitter pour toujours
faisons attention c'est le point et
nous avons une bonne alchimie entre nous
nous sommes toujours heureux parce que nous sommes
parler d'amour de faire les choses avec amour
nous allons donner notre vie pour
notre peuple
celui-ci est sorti torero nain
[des rires]
la clé d'amortisseur ok j'y vais pas
arrêter de chercher mes frères
migrants jusqu'à dieu
mesurer que vous ne pouvez plus ange
[Musique]
c'est très difficile
mais
et je ne vais pas m'arrêter
[Musique]
Je continuerai à chercher mon peuple
tant que les murs sont fermés ils ne partent pas
arrêter et vous en aurez toujours besoin
et nous serons là pour eux
elles ou ils
ils sont humains aussi
et ils ont besoin d'une chance